we are back in bucharest romania with
the first leg of the granchester the
super bad chess classic what are your
thoughts on this event and how does it
feel to be playing here in bucharest
yeah it's going to be exciting i mean
i'm very glad to be here back here in
romania
i am very grateful to the sponsors for
having this uh
and it's a new start it's a new season
it's a very strong tournament with all
the top players we'll see how it goes
so yeah this is for me a new experience
i like visiting new places actually it's
you know i always feel like uh going
from tournament to tournament pretty
much playing the same players and
everything it kind of gets boring you
fall into the same pattern same routine
so i like at least that there's for me
at least a new environment and
even though the players are pretty much
the same right this can
this can make it interesting and
yeah i'm looking forward to it of course
it's very nice we're good to back uh
again i i played here in bucharest only
one time and i played very good
tournament it's not easy tournament is
every chess player come in this
tournament and for this reason
to play good
it will be not easy but we all will try
yeah i was always watching it
from
live from home on
previous years i think it's a very well
organized tournament
and it's a very top tournament and also
very tough so i think it's great to be
here in romania i heard a lot of good
things about this country and i was
always i've always wanted to visit here
so
i look forward to the tournament and i
try and do my best
i feel good
i'm obsessed that last time i was pretty
sick for for the duration of the event
so that was not a great experience
only because of that because otherwise
things have been organized
to very high standards so i was
definitely looking forward to
to be back here and my shape
at least i'm not feeling sick at all so
it should be very good i've been coming
to bucharest since early 90s great city
and a city that
i love being in yeah and now i have many
friends here so i really
enjoy the old town and
generally the whole city and
it's love towards chess
well first time here in romania and
obviously i'm very happy to be you know
back on track and
play first classical event since
whatever november and december
yeah it's my first time visiting romania
it's always nice
to visit new places as a chess player
that's one of the pluses
the best players in the world come back
in romania it's
very good for romania and cheese in
romania
[Music]